once you didn't have a leg you're like
all right I need to be beneficial to my
team in other ways Beyond just physical
you know you're gonna be able to hold
this standard and I would say you
probably do a hell a lot better than the
standard but you're like hey there might
be some deficiencies that I have because
I only have one freaking leg so I'm
gonna make up for that and you started
going to some of the more cerebral parts
of Special Forces started going to
schools to learn you know operational
Art and Design and and that way you had
something else to offer it was like
almost like a backup plan if you didn't
have it all physically which again I
would I would I would say you definitely
have a physical but if you had some
slack there you're gonna be able to make
up for